aussi à celle des louise faubert de
saint-girons il n'y a aucun cas de
covile 19
de quoi donner le sourire aux employés
qui travaillent d'arrache-pied pour que
cela reste ainsi
même avec le retour imminent des projets
dans il va avoir une mise en place de
procédures qu'il faudra que les gens
respectent pour éviter justement de
contamination interne
ça va être le même processus que vous au
fond il va y avoir un questionnaire à
l'entrée un contrôle de la température
après être entrés à l'intérieur on se
lave les mains on file un masque
chirurgical des lunettes de protection
une jaquette et dégâts si on est au
deuxième étage où on a installé l'enfant
notre zone gens qu'on appelle la zone
tiennent et notre fesseur zone rouge
quand t'en vas avoir d'école de positif
mais d'abord la zone verte où zones
froides où les résidents peuvent se
promener librement dans la musique et
des jeux mais on essaie de garder le
plus la distanciation possible
on peut voir ici malgré qu'on attend
dans le froid on a quand même installé
des denis porte pour notre clientèle qui
fait de l'errance invasif se considérer
comme étant une convention parce que
celle limite la personne dans sa
mobilité
mais pour contrer la pandémie on a
décidé d'appliquer strictement les
mesures de prévention des infections
ensuite direction la zone jaune de
l'autre côté du bâtiment
ici les résidents sont isolés puisqu'ils
ont des symptômes d'alluré grippale
ici on vient d'entrer dans la zone rouge
nous avons personnes actuellement la
détester positif à la coved cependant ni
près des chambres ont été libérés pour
accueillir d'éventuels malades
les employés qui viendront ici ne
travaillerons exclusivement que dans la
zone rouge qui sera séparée des autres
unités mais elle espère ne pas utiliser
les chambres vides certaines sont
inquiètes
entre autres du retour des proches
aidants de savoir qu'on ouvrait les
portes ça va leur amener un petit peu de
stress pour vous dire ça mais écrire un
petit peu puis on se pose des questions
c'est normal mais je pense que ça va
super bien nous surtout ici et pas de
formule magique personne est à l'abri de
la coved 19 ans le vu tantôt le retraité
des équipements de protection
individuelle ça nécessite une certaine
complexité un centre anglais rigueur
tout pour que le coronavirus n'entre pas
dans ce ch et celle des on n'est pas à
l'abri on sait jamais mais on veut pas
lâcher prise parce qu'on en a pas on
essaie d'être rigoureuse par elsa on en
a pas on n'en veut pas ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada saint-girons